thanks Nikhil so I work with students
Mohan Tina's right here he was a
undergraduate at Carnegie Mellon when we
reckon this together but now he's a grad
student at Berkeley so you can see him
around and high-five em in halls okay so
we proved some things about a variety of
infinite graphs and I'll say what
infinite graphs in particularly later
but for now just give you some examples
to which our results are going to apply
so here's one of course I can only show
you a finite picture of them but this is
the infinite graph where you like take a
triangle and in each vertex you attach
two edges and then at every vertex
there's like attached a triangle and two
edges and for the sophisticates this is
the free product of the triangle and two
edges here's another one this is just
the infinite three regular tree which
i'll call t sub 3 in this talk that's an
important example and again for a
sophisticated people is the free product
of three edge graphs that's T for the
infinite for regular tree this is a non
regular graph but it in a very simple
way this is the infinite by regular
three comma four tree I just put this up
here to say that some of the other
graphs will not be regular there's
another graph that's even simpler than
earlier ones but it's the product of
like a free product of a triangle and an
edge and I only put this one up so I can
say this fancy name apparently it's the
kelly graph of the modular group there's
another graph this is the free product
of 4 3 4 cycles to 4 cycles and then you
pulse on this one for a second this is
another infinite graph that kind of
looks like you put down C 4 with - sorry
K 4 - an edge and then another copy of K
4 - an edge and cetera in such a way
that the diagonals don't touch there's
not the free product of any particular
graph so in fact it's I wrote this tiny
thing down here so one thing that we do
in this paper has introduced a new kind
of graph product that takes some finite
graphs on the same vertex sets and when
you graph product them you get an
infinite graph so I'll explain more
about that later about this infinite
graph is we call this the additive
product
the additive product of these two little
graphs and the it depends on the
labeling that vertex labeling of the
graph so these are not the same graph
and I don't here's one more example it's
not clear cuz free product of graphs
actually involves them having a route
the only free product of routed graphs
so many of the nicest examples involved
like little graphs that are
vertex-transitive and then it doesn't
really matter what the route is yeah so
here's one more like random example it's
all it's again gonna be one of these
additive products that we invent and I
put it up here because these graphs
don't even have to be connected okay
anyway so there's gonna be some wide
family of infinite graphs involved and
we're gonna prove some things about
their spectrum and eigen values and
stuff like that okay so the story is
going to involve fixing one particular
infinite graph X like I don't know maybe
this one and then what we're gonna do is
look at all the graphs which are so
called finite quotients of these graphs
all the finite graphs here's the
definition but basically a finite graph
G and this talk G will be a finite graph
and X will be like one of these nice big
infinite graphs Jesus the quotient of X
if it kind of like locally resembles X
so more properly there should be some
surjection from the infinite graph to
the finite graph that locally looks like
a bite Jackson I'll give you some
examples well basically we're gonna be
looking at you know once you fix the big
infinite graph X look of finite graph G
that locally resemble it okay so this is
the first thing when a graph we looked
at and here's an example I mean it's not
easy to tell right away but here's an
example of a finite graph G which is
covered by this infinite graph and in
fact this the set of finite graphs
covered by this infinite graph are all
those four regular graphs where every
vertex participates in a triangle it's
not too hard to prove
okay so this graph sort of locally
resembles this graph now these things
are not necessarily unique so this graph
is also covered by or a quotient of the
infinite for regular tree okay so one
graph can be covered by different
infinite graphs and in fact the set of
all finite quotients of the infinite for
regular tree are just the four regular
graphs okay so this is a still a four
regular graph but had this additional
property actually that every vertex
participated in a cycle the three cycle
which meant it was also covered by the
previous guy
so fixing an infinite graphics we're
gonna be studying all the finite graphs
that are quotients of it and it's a
simple fact that all of these graphs
have the same largest eigenvalue so I'm
going to use this notation lambda 1
through lambda and for the eigenvalues
of the adjacency matrix of the graph G
ordered from largest to smallest okay so
all the finite quotients of an infinite
graph of the same largest eigenvalue and
in particular if the infinite graph is
Delta regular then so we're all the
finite graphs and this common eigenvalue
is the trivial eigenvalue namely Delta
okay so I like this you know we're gonna
be talking about expanders and Robin
nutrient graphs and so forth we're gonna
be interested in how small the second
largest eigenvalue of these finite graph
g can be among all the graphs covered by
x all the graphs that locally resemble x
and you know one reason for this is that
this gap between the largest eigenvalue
and the second largest eigenvalue is
some kind of spectral measure of how
good and expander this small graph g is
you know if you are the thing about
expanders and you also might worry about
how large the the negative smallest
eigen value of g is but we're not gonna
worry about this in this talk so we're
only gonna be worried about how far away
lambda two is from lambda 1 or how small
the second-largest eigenvalue can be
okay so we're you know again fixing X
we're interested in statements that look
like this you know for given X there are
infinitely many finite graphs that are
covered by X whose second largest
eigenvalue is smaller than some number
Rho star we want to get a lot of finite
graphs that have small second eigenvalue
and the first thing we should ask
ourselves is what's the best possible
Rho star the smallest possible Rho star
we could ever put here and there's a
barrier to how small this can be that
comes from X so you may have seen this
before in the context of just Delta
regular graphs it's that alone Befana
theorem and there's generalizations of
it by greenberg and Grich or Chuck and
Zook and others and what they say is you
could never put if a row star here any
number which is smaller than the
spectral radius of X that is to say the
largest eigen value in magnitude of the
infinite like parent graph X yes that's
right you couldn't function
yes good
okay so the classical um boppin or
theorem case is when the the infinite
graph is just a delta regular tree and
so the finite quotients of it that we're
studying that just means all the Delta
regular graphs it's a well-known fact
that the spectral radius of this
infinite Delta regular tree is this
magic number 2 square root Delta minus 1
and therefore the alone Befana theorem
in this case says that whenever you have
a finite Delta regular graph with n
vertices its second largest eigen value
has to be at least basically 2 root
Delta minus 1 minus little of 1
actually you can say if stronger things
and this is commonly attributed to Sarah
the stronger result that in fact for any
fixed K even the Kaif largest eigenvalue
has to be at least to this magic number
2 root Delta minus 1 minus little o of 1
and even that linear fraction of the
eigenvalues have to be bigger than this
spectral radius of the infinite graph
and this has a generalization to the
case where this infinite graph is not
just the regular tree and it's not just
tree at all in fact so in fact Grigore
Chuck and Juke showed that for every
infinite graph X if you look at all the
finite graphs covered by it their
second-largest eigenvalue always has to
be basically at least the spectral
radius of X in fact this stronger
generalization about a linear fraction
of the eigenvalues is also true
good so that kind of tells us if we're
interested in studying finite covers of
acts like what the smallest thing we
could sort of shoot for potentially is
here for the second largest eigenvalue
okay so let's put yourself back in the
mind of just X being the infinite Delta
regular tree and therefore the the grass
were interested in being the Delta
regular graphs so we have this along
bopanna theorem and then the traditional
definition of a Delta regular graph
being ramen Adrienne is just to say that
this bound is met in other words that
the second largest eigen value of G is
at most this magic number the spectral
radius of the infinite Delta regular
tree and these are really cool graphs at
the optimal spectral expanders among in
this case Delta regular graphs okay
motivation in this paper was to study
the same question but not for graphs
that locally resemble regular trees may
locally resemble some other infinite
looking graph infinite graph great so as
to whether there are any such ramen
eating grass oh sorry I didn't say this
here so here's the general definition
that we're gonna work with so it's a
general notion of being ramen nutrient
and it's not a property of the finite
graph it's sort of a property in some
sense of the fixed infinite graph so you
fix an infinite graph X and then you say
that a graph a finite graph covered by
that X is X ramanuja if it's
second-largest eigenvalue it's bounded
by the spectral radius of X I think this
definition is due to gregor chickens
hook
okay so as for the existence question in
the case where you have the infinite
Delta regular tree it's a result of
boskie Philips Sonic and morghulis that
these guys exist whenever Delta minus
one is a prime constructed infinitely
many of them and this was upgraded to
prime power by Morgenstern and then this
was just upgraded to any value of Delta
by Markus Spielman and Shrivastava and
they did via the interlacing polynomials
method that we heard about a Nima's talk
so great this existing question solved
when X is the infinite Delta regular
tree in fact they proved more in there
the interlacing polynomials for they
basically show the same result more or
less for X being any infinite tree any
infinite tree which covers at least one
graph which is to say any universal
cover tree X so if you look at on the
paper they show that whenever X is some
infinite tree and it covers you know
some finite graph G 0 they show that
there are infinitely many lifts G of G 0
so I'll get into talking about lifts
later but this is a way of constructing
larger finite graphs from smaller finite
graphs so in particular all these lifts
G of G 0 will also be covered by X such
that basically all the eigenvalues of
the resulting graph except for constant
number are bounded by the spectral
radius of X so it's a fact that when you
take a base graph G 0 and form a lift of
it the eigenvalues of the lifted graph
are include all the eigenvalues of the
base graph including the the trivial one
the largest one and so they showed you
can always find lifts infinitely many
lifts where all the newly-created
eigenvalues are upper bounded by this
target the spectral radius of the
infinite tree X ok so particularly the
base graph itself is Ramanuja n-- if you
find like one Ramanujan base graph whose
all but top Augen value are bounded by
the spectral radius then so will be all
the lifts
proved conjectures of Elul inial and P
Clark
so as I said this shows that if you just
have to what single X Ramanujan graph G
0 in the case where X is a tree then
there are infinitely many X Ramanujan
graph so infinitely many Ramanujan
graphs for this infinite tree and even
if you can't find this base Rama
nutrient graph it's still kind of cool I
mean it's still kind of ok you get
something that Clark P Clark calls a
quasi Ramanuja graph just whatever like
annoying eigen values in the basic graph
were bigger than the spectral radius of
X stick around but all the other ones
will be bounded by the spectral radius
of X ok so they'll be this just notice
that like at most K 0 eigen values are
above the bound that you care about
this is natural given that these like
stronger alone Befana theorems that say
that even a linear fraction of the
spectrum has to be basically at least
the the spectral radius of X
okay so uh this is all for trees well as
I mentioned before we kind of want to do
the same thing our motivation was to do
the same thing but for infant graphs
that are not trees in other words for
graphs that have like some short cycles
in them you know graphs that resemble
some of these infinite graphs the
pictures which I was showing you at the
beginning and our main theorem is that
this same theorem exact same theorem
holds for any info graph X which is an
additive product graph and I'll explain
what that is later but in particular
that includes all universal cover trees
it includes all graphs which are free
products of vertex-transitive graphs
which is kind of a lot of the
nice-looking infinite infinite graphs
include some other graphs questions yeah
[Music]
one relation a 1 B 1 a 1
as one so it's a one relation it's not a
free product so and nobody knows how to
compute the spectrum over there ya know
so yeah what two things I'll say one is
that this raises an interesting point
which is that we're gonna prove this
theorem without necessarily computing
the spectral radius of X yeah so
actually going to prove this even
without like knowing what is the
spectral radius of X that's one question
the thing I'll say and I don't know all
the details of the example you asked but
like an example graph X that we care
about and don't know what to do with
would be like the infinite grid graph
look Z to it would be that's not an
additive product graph but we would be
interested in in that
okay so we want to follow the same
method of you know producing large
finite graphs that are X Ramanuja graphs
but there's a problem the only way we
know how to do this in the the usual
case the normal case produces graphs
that locally resemble trees but we don't
want graphs that locally resemble trees
so we need to invent a new kind of lift
which I'll tell you about it is we call
the additive lifts so let me define what
is the additive lifts and they're gonna
be random additive lifts so I'll sort of
define random additive lifts all in one
shot so the funny thing is we're not
going to apply this just to one base
graph we're gonna talk about additively
lifting a collection of finite graphs
and all these graphs are gonna have the
same vertex set and we like to call
these sub these final graphs atoms and
we also like to color them so let a 1
through AC be graphs on the same vertex
set and we're going to talk about
additively lifting this list of c graphs
here's gonna be my running example I
have 4 atoms in this case and they're
all on the same three vertices UVW a 1
is a triangle and the other three are
just single edges but they remember
there's I mean I don't delete this
isolated vertex so I'm going to talk
about making additive lifts of this
collection of four graphs but before you
go out of lift let me talk about two
simpler operations on collections of
graphs the first operation is very
simple it's just summing some times I
can identify a graphs with their jason c
matrix and summing just means put the
graphs on top of each other or some the
adjacency matrices so in this particular
running example when I sum these four
graphs I get this multi graph we're
gonna be fine with multi graphs in this
talk so we get the two copies of the
triangle okay so that's summing an
operation on collections of graphs atoms
on the same vertex set ok the next
operation I need to tell you about and
by the way the additive lists are going
to be a combination of summing and this
operation the second operation is called
making a balanced lift of a single item
okay so it's gonna resemble a normal
lift of atoms but it's gonna be a
special case of this well in the end
we'll we'll come to a generalization let
me tell you what it means a balanced
of a single atom like this triangle
graph so in a balanced R fold lift it's
going to sort of resemble the normal
lifts which perhaps you've seen before
of a graph so step one is you make our
copies of the vertex set so in my
example here R is gonna be four I'm
gonna make a four fold balanced lift of
this triangle and I'm gonna put some
edges in here so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to put a random
permutation on the symmetric group of
order four or are on each vertex this is
different from the usual list where you
put random permutations on the edges I'm
gonna put a random permutation on each
vertex ok so here's an example but now
I'm going to get permutations on the
edges by taking the quotients okay so
for every edge in the graph I'm going to
take the quotient between the
permutation on the vertices which I
Phyllis rated here you can trust me on
that
and now I have a permutation on each
edge and now I'm going to do like the
usual lifting of I going to put up a
matching between let's say for every
pair of vertices U and V in the original
graph I'm going to be put a matching
between the u vertices and the V
vertices here according to this
permutation that's on the edge now these
are usual lifts of the base graph
perhaps it'll look like this here but
they're not as general as possible
there's something special about them in
particular you see because of this
permutation on Versys thing these edge
permutations have the property that
whenever you walk around a cycle you get
back to the identity permutation because
all the quotients like cancel out okay
this graph is a bit funny because it the
whole graph is one cycle but in general
the this Adam graph has you know some
cycles in it then these edge
permutations will have the property this
is the balance this property that when
you go around the cycle and multiply the
edge permutations you get back to the
identity permutation which means that
the same cycles occur back in this big
graph and therefore for example this big
graph will have short
cycles all the time if this base graph
has cycles which is something that
doesn't more or less happen in a random
usual lift in fact it's more than that
it's not hard to show that they are just
gonna say here that the in the usual
lifts their usual random lifts you just
put independent random permutations on
the edges and then do this construction
so this is a special case of the the
usual lifts and it's like not hard to
show that when you do this operation and
you just get are disjoint copies of the
base graph so in this picture which I
just widened a little bit here it should
be the union of four triangles which it
is so there's one two three four this
edge is just going behind this u3 it's
not connecting to it yeah so it's a bit
of a structured way to make are disjoint
copies of the base graph okay so it may
look like I'm defining something less in
general than the normal random lifts but
actually when I put it together with the
summing operation we'll see in a second
that it's it can be more general any
questions
okay so right so I defined some ink
based graphs and I defined balance lifts
and now to make a random additive lift
you just do both so you do a random
balanced lift of each atom and then you
just put the results on top of each
other so here's an example this is a
four-fold lift I created of each of the
four based graphs it's a little hard to
see then you put them on top of each
other and then this is the lifted graph
there are inherently colors or the
colors are just illustrative it's just
this ugly graph here's another example
this is a tenfold lift of the original
graph remember the original four atoms
were like one triangle and then three
edges and you see that this tenfold lift
yeah you see like the disjoint yellow
triangles in it and in each vertex it's
connected also to two edges independent
ones for the different atoms
bucks
good let me make actually we're just one
small remark on these balanced lifts
whenever you have a single edge or in
fact more generally a forest the
balanced lifts are the same as the usual
lifts or a balanced random lift is the
same as usual random lifts because there
are no cycles
okay so although let me tell you now
actually how these random additive lifts
in fact generalize the usual random
lifts and it's gonna be by an operation
that I'll say a few times let's say you
just have like one base graph you're
just in the world of one graph the thing
I always want you to do in this talk is
imagine like going to this world of like
atoms by exploding it into what I'll
call its edge atoms in other words just
writing it as a some kind of like an e
my digits talk with the little edge
laplacian a sum of one edge graphs
okay so always whenever I have like one
graph I'll like convert it to the sum of
one edge graphs oh I think I've to say
this in words so imagine what happens if
we do an additive lift of these four
atoms now first we do like a random
balanced lift of each of these single
edge graphs but as I said before I mean
okay you take the quotient of two random
permutations you just get a random
permutation so these will just turn into
like random etchings between the
appropriate pairs of vertices and then
you'll add them back up and this is
exactly what you do in the usual random
lifts if you're familiar with the usual
random lifts
okay so if you just sort with any one
thing is if you start with any graph
here explore it out to its edge items
and do this additive random added look
to it the resulting graph is just a
random usual lift of the base original
base graph
okay so again here's my running example
of four atoms and if I do a four fold
out and have left it might look like
this and if I did a 10 fold out of left
it might look like this and what if I do
like in a million fold additive lift
what will the graph look like
well in fact I want to ask you know it's
as R goes to infinity what infinite
graph does an R fold additive lift
locally resemble you can imagine it
right it's basically gonna be like in
this particular case like the infinite
graph or let's say you plunk down a
yellow triangle and then if this is
vertex u then you would attach like a
pink edge and a blue edge and then at
those vertices you know you would attach
one copy of each of the other graphs and
so forth I mean it's kind of like yeah I
mean when you do the balance lift it's
kind of imagine that they're like no
like coincidences about like when you
start walking for a bit that you come
back to a layer you've seen except for
those necessary ones based on the fact
that like well there's gonna be copies
of the cycles on the base graph in your
graph so actually want to say just the
answer is what we're going to define the
additive product to be so that infinite
graph that maybe you can imagine is what
I'll take it's the definition of this
additive product of these four atoms so
of course in the paper are we've you
know write a proper definition of what
is the additive lift of some atoms and
it resembles the definition of the
universal cover tree but it's a bit more
annoying but you can get the correct
idea just by saying oh it's the bottom
photograph that these things resemble
when you take larger and larger lifts so
I'll draw you some pictures here to
illustrate it so the additive product of
these four atoms is this infinite graph
again the colors are just for
illustration but you know you basically
you plunked down a copy of one of the
graphs it doesn't matter which one you
start with and then put copies of all
the other graphs on the vertices that
you haven't touched in the vertices you
still haven't touched you put copies of
all the base graphs that touch that
vertex sort of and so forth
okay so here's an example another
example if I just have two atoms that
look like this then they're additive
product is the infinite graph that
starts to look like this okay so again
you put them a copy of this graph and
then on each vertex attach this graph
appropriately with the labels of the
vertices and so forth
and also now let's put it in mind put
yourself in mind at the case where
you're just given one graph was there a
question okay you're just given one
graph and you want to use this
construction of exploding it out into
like the sum of its edges so if we do
that and then ask what is the additive
product of the edges the thing you
actually get is the universal cover tree
of the original graph okay so in this
case you'll get the infinite three
regular tree so in some sense this
additive products that we introduced
generalizes the notion of taking the
universal cover tree of a base graph
okay couple more examples the additive
product of these three four cycles gives
you this graph we're like infinite graph
for each vertex three four cycles are
attached okay so this is a way that
gives us our infinite graph which we
like to call X and it's a fact that all
these finally additive lifts G of your
collection of atoms are covered by this
infinite graph so tiny asterisks here
this is only true if the finite additive
lift is connected which it will be with
high probability
but basically ignore this asterisk so
now you we sort of see a recipe by which
we can attack this X Ramanujan question
if we have some infinite graph X which
is the additive product of some atoms
which gives us a wide variety of
interesting-looking infinite graphs X
then we can produce plenty of finite
graph G which are covered by this X just
by taking these additive lifts these
finite additive lifts of the atoms
they're not homogeneous point they are
somewhat the maps of the infinite things
itself to preserve edges will have
finally many orbits yes the autumn or
prism have finally many orbits so
they're yeah so that then you have a
group which acts on that and in terms of
group Theory you don't have a
description of what you guys up I do
it's a good question very well
yeah so just to repeat what the answer
to the question was in particularly
these additive products these infinite
graphs they're quite symmetric in a
certain sense it's not the case that
every vertex resembles every other
vertex sometimes that is the case right
in this graph infinite graph it's
vertex-transitive every vertex is kind
of the same as every other vertex that's
vertex-transitive in general these
additive graphs will have the property
that like there'll be at most you know T
classes of vertices where T is the
number of vertices in the base graphs
such that every vertex in the same class
you know resembles each other so in
general in the infinite graph they'll be
like in this case there'll be you type
vertices V type vertices W type vertices
and X type vertices now here this base
graph is vertex-transitive so really
there's ultimately only one type of
vertex but you can have any arbitrary
you know for vertex graph here and then
in the most general situation and the
infinite graph that's the additive
product will have like four different
kinds of vertices
okay good so now we get on to this
Ramanujan question which involves
understanding the eigenvalues of these
things so in particular we're interested
in the eigenvalues of additive lifts
this is a finite operation additive
lifts of a bunch of atoms and similar to
the usual case when you do the additive
lifts of a bunch of atoms you retain the
original eigenvalues of the sum of the
atoms and then you get some like new
eigenvalues and a cool dream would be if
one could show that when you do a random
additive lift of a bunch of atoms a 1
through a c with high probability these
new eigenvalues that you get are all
bounded by the spectral radius of the
infinite graph this infinite additive
product and if you had that you would be
I would apply the theorem that we have
that for any additive product there are
infinitely many basically X Ramanujan
graphs technically you should have to
put quasi here because there might have
been some like annoying to large values
in your original some graph but either
perhaps you can show that that's not the
case or you can just tolerate the fact
that you're infinitely many graphs might
have like a couple of two large
eigenvalues
okay but much like in the Marcus Biel
industry Basava paper is we do not
achieve that but we achieve the worst
thing that this holds with nonzero
probability which is just us you know
somewhat silly way to say that for every
value are there exists an are fold
additive lift of your base graphs G such
that the new eigenvalues of this are
fold lifts are bounded by the spectral
radius of the big infinite graph okay
then in particular this is kind of like
if you know this stuff real well is
similar to the situation MSS for
interlacing Paulo meals for for every
are every large value of our you can do
an R fold lift there exist an hour fold
lift that has nicely bounded eigen
values and there's this really nice
paper by Hall pooter and saw in which is
kind of like interlacing polynomials v
if you will where they generalize some
of the stuff in the the sequence of MSS
papers but for the rest of this talk I'm
not going to talk about the showing this
for a general value of r for general all
fold lifts I'll just say as in MSS one
talk about additive two lifts to fold
lifts and then once you actually know
for to fold minutes you can more let's
get the desired theorem by just keep
doing two lifts and you'll get like
larger and larger the existence of
larger and larger graphs all of which
are covered by the infinite out of
product and all of whose second eigen
values are bounded by the spectral
radius in fact given all the previous
work the R fold case kind of reduces to
the twofold case in the end anyway
okay so now we're in a situation where
you have some atoms and we're gonna be
studying twofold random lifts of them
and trying to understand the eigenvalues
of the resulting graphs okay so now the
thing that happens is there's something
that happens that's also similar to the
the usual lifting case which is that you
can characterize the new eigenvalues you
get when you do an additive to lifts in
a slightly simpler way so the new
eigenvalues of the additive to lift of a
bunch of atoms there's you always retain
the old Ligon values of the sun graph
the new eigenvalues are the same as the
eigen values you would get at a random
balanced edge signing of the atoms the
sum of such a thing it just this will
become a little bit clearer like imagine
what happens when you do a random
additive to lift of some atoms I'll kind
of remind you of the definition you put
a random permutation on each vertex of
an atom which is either the identity
permutation on 1 & 2 or it's the
transposition and then you take the
quotients to get a permutation which is
again either identity or transposition
on each edge and they make this kind of
like just double cover a kind of thing
where each old edge becomes either just
a parallel matching or a cross matching
and it's very similar to just if you
take the the edges instead of putting
identity or a transposition and making a
little two vertex by partha graph you
just put a sign of plus or minus on each
edge so that's what's going on here so
not to annoy you by giving another
definition of what is a balanced edge
signing of an atom so what is a balanced
edge signing it's basically you put a
random sign plus or minus one on each
vertex preliminarily and then you
convert those two edge signs by again
taking the quotient or it's the same as
product of the vertices that are the
endpoints okay so a balanced edge
signing is a way to give or random
balanced edge signing is a way to give
an edge sign to each edge in the base
graph but the balance this property is
again this property that for every
cycle that may exist in the these graphs
the product of the signs is going to be
positive its plus one okay so it's a
special kind of edge signing that's set
up so that whenever you go around a
cycle the product of the edge side the
signs is plus one okay and that's
actually where the name balance comes
from in the graph theory literature so
this random additive to lift is from the
point of view of eigenvalue is basically
the same as doing the following you take
your atoms you do a random balanced edge
signing of each atom and then you just
again literally add the resulting
adjacency matrices and whoops this will
give you a multi graph like a graph with
integer entries which is fine you can
think of this as three parallel edges
and it's possible that you know plus one
cancels with a minus one and that edge
goes away that's fine so yeah this
random to lift you can analyze its new
eigenvalues by understanding just the
normal eigen values of the adjacency
matrix you get by this operation give it
a random balanced edge signing to each
atom and adding the results
okay some thrown a lot of stuff out you
hear but let's keep going okay so let's
get to polynomials that's why we're all
here right let's write in a nice way
what is the new weighted adjacency
matrix when you do this random balanced
edge signing plus summing operation so a
nice way to write it is let Q 1 through
Q C be random diagonal matrices where
the diagonal entries are random signs
and now if you conjugate the adjacency
matrix a 1 by Q 1 you can easily check
that that exactly gives you a random
balanced edge signing of the graph okay
so when Q is a random diagonal sign
matrix Q transpose or whatever qaq gives
a random balanced edge signing of a so
that's what we're doing independently
for each of the atoms and then we're
just adding the results to get the
adjacency matrix of the results so
actually if you've seen the finite free
convolution and stuff it's quite similar
except instead of random whatever
unitary matrices were conjugating the
A's by random diagonal sign matrices
and now we want to understand the
eigenvalues of this guy this matrix okay
so just to remind you what we want the
show this is a you know the theorems is
exactly the thing we want to show you
have any atoms a 1 through a C do these
random diagonal sign matrices conjugate
the atoms by them add them get a matrix
you look at its eigenvalues we want to
show that apply probability or at least
nonzero probability the maximum
eigenvalue is bounded by the spectral
radius of the infinite graph this
infinite additive product graph you know
so much it early we're going to do this
without actually knowing what this
number is and it's just another small
comment to relate it to the final free
convolution stuff you know this
distribution on Q is not unitarily
invariant so like if these were random
unitary x' then the result would only
depend on the eigenvalues of a but it's
not so like this operation really
depends on the whole matrix of phase
okay so now we're in a situation which
is quite similar to NEMA stock so glad
you're all here for that so first we're
just going to use some change of
terminology instead of saying the
eigenvalues of this matrix will say
roots of the characteristic polynomial
of this matrix and this is bad notation
but I guess the most common notation for
characteristic polynomial is Phi so I'll
stick with that good and now you're like
hey interlacing polynomials method and
by virtue of it
we show it's not too hard to show that
instead it suffice to look at the
maximum root of the expected
characteristic polynomial of this random
matrix of course if you've never seen
the relation polynomial method before it
like makes no sense that like reasoning
about the maximum root of the expected
characteristic polynomial would tell you
anything about the maximum roots of like
an on average polynomial but you know it
does so yeah so we have to prove that
the interlacing polynomials method
applies to this situation
which involves showing that various of
these polynomials are real rooted which
they are all are I will skip that
actually it's basically almost an
immediate application of a theorem in
the Hall of Peter saw in paper which in
turn is basically just a reworking of a
theorem that's in MSS four so you know
you apply those things and you find that
everything is real rooted and the method
applies one thing I showed that sit on
pointed out to me just before this talk
though is that there's a this is a
univariate polynomial there's a natural
multivariate polynomial you could have
here and that guy is not real stable in
general but nevertheless this polynomial
which is univariate is real rooted so
you have to use I guess the techniques
in these papers to show it
okay so skipping over that it now
suffice is to understand the roots of
this expected characteristic polynomial
so let's start by giving this object a
name so we're gonna call it the additive
characteristic polynomial of this
collection of atoms and I'll call it
alpha of these things so there's a
univariate polynomial I didn't write the
variable name okay and as I said you can
show that it's real rooted using
basically previous theorems in fact
we're not gonna need that for the rest
of the proof what we're gonna show is
that the maximum magnitude root of this
polynomial is always at most the
spectral radius of this infinite graph
what you need the real rootedness to
make the interlacing polynomial stuff
work so we need to start understanding
the roots of this expected
characteristic polynomial just kind of
complicated let's try to warm up to
understand this additive characteristic
polynomial a bit
so okay this is yes this is going to
generalize the theorem that the matching
polynomial of a graph has its roots
bounded in the interval you know even by
the spectral radius of the universal
covering tree which is you know - Rudy -
one well it's kind of similar to one of
God sales proofs
Oh baby okay let's clean it in the case
when there's only one Adam so you're
taking a random balance edge signing of
it taking the characteristic polynomial
taking the expectation well these Q's
are unitary so actually conjugating
matrix by unitary this doesn't change
its roots so in that case you just get
the characteristic polynomial back okay
now this is an interesting special case
to imagine you take one graph GE and you
do this operation of exploding it out
into the edge Adams so writing is the
sum of single edge graphs then what is
this additive characteristic polynomial
well the a balanced edge signing of a
graph of an edge a random one is just
the random edge signing so you get a
random the expected value of the
characteristic polynomial of a random
edge signing of G and it's a theorem by
god's little goodman that this is the
thing called the matching polynomial of
the graph which is usually defined in a
comma toriel way so are additive
characteristic polynomial also
generalizes the matching polynomial and
let me tell you a sketch you a proof of
this theorem because we'll kind of need
it in our general scenario okay so the
usual definition of the matching
polynomial given a graph G and an
indeterminate X is it's kind of a
generating function for the matchings in
partial matchings in the graph
stratified by number of vertices
involved so it's a polynomial the kaif
coefficient of which is basically up to
this minus one sign the number of
matchings in the graph with K vertices
okay so why is that also equal to this
expected characteristic polynomial of a
random edge signing of the adjacency
matrix well here's the proof
take me expected characteristic
polynomial so we should look at the
coefficients of the characteristic
polynomial and there's a totally
disgusting formula for the coefficients
of the characteristic polynomial of a
graph that you can get just by like
expanding out the definition of what is
a determinant here what you do is the
cave coefficient you sum over all
basically disjoint cycles in the on the
vertex set that have K vertices and
there's some negative 1 thing going on
and then actually for general matrix a
you take the product of the edge weights
around all the edges in the cycles okay
if these are adjacent C matrixes of
graphs then this quantity is just 1 or 0
depending on whether or not the cycle is
in the graph so some kind of
characteristic polynomial for sorry it's
some kind of generating function for
objects which are like collection vertex
disjoint collections of cycles in the
graph so you can get that and now we're
taking the expected value of these
coefficients when you randomly edge sine
the edges you might think if you have
like one cycle and then you look at the
product of the entries around that cycle
and then taking an expectation if you're
randomly signing the edges you would
think that expectation would be 0 and
therefore you think everything would be
0 and everything would drop out and you
get the 0 polynomial but that's not
quite right because of two cycles so if
you have a two cycle in the graph which
is just going back and forth on an edge
in a random edge signing you know the
back and forth on the edge they get the
same sign so the product of the signs
around a two cycle is always 1 and
therefore all the terms which are not
two cycles dropout and so instead of
summing over collections of disjoint any
cycles you sum over collections of
disjoint two cycles in other words you
sum over partial matchings
so that was a little fast you don't have
to fully get that whole proof but I'll
say some similar words later and I
wanted to warm you up for it so this is
a sketch of the proof of why the
generating function of matchings is the
same as this I expect not I'm not sure
okay so you can do a similar thing I
mean now we have to understand this
expected characteristic polynomial of
this object and you can do a similar
just argument and you get sort of a
formula for the coefficients of this
additive characteristic polynomial and
it looks kind of the same it's basically
the keith's coefficient counts the
number of collections of disjoint cycles
with K total vertices where each cycle
has to appear in one of the atoms
okay so disjoint colored cycles as we
call them okay so that gives us some
kind of formula for the coefficients of
this thing which is good because we're
gonna be averaging a bunch of these
polynomials and the coefficients of the
final average polynomial are the
averages of the coefficients that's
good and you can see again like how you
get the the the generating function for
matchings back here if you take one
graph and explode it out into atoms
where each atom is a single edge and
then you look at all the collections of
cycles where each cycle comes from one
of the atoms you again get matchings
because the only cycles and the atoms
are just single edges
okay so we have these three polynomials
and we have to understand the
eigenvalues and I personally really only
know one way of understanding
eigenvalues or roots of the
characteristic polynomial which is via
the trace method and the trace method it
says that if you have a graph G the K
power sum of the eigenvalues is equal to
the number of closed length K walks in G
this actually this these numbers are the
coefficients of like the log derivative
of the characteristic polynomial so it's
another little connection to Nima's talk
now we all want to prove this in a very
simple way via linear algebra but what
if you wanted to prove this in a
horrible way via the only thing I told
you at the characteristic polynomial
which is that you can write down this
like disgusting formula for its
coefficients you should be able to do
that you should be able to deduce this
combinatorial thing about flows length K
walks in G from this definitions
horrible definition of the
characteristic polynomial and you can
and it just uses like highly classical
generating functions stuff techniques
and the way somehow it's kind of uses
like a combinatorial interpretation of
the Newton relations and basically like
all I'll say at a high level is like
this is some kind of generating from the
coefficients here are some kind of
generating function for collections of
disjoint directed cycles in G and this K
power sum of the roots involves like
closed walks of length K and the
connection between these two objects is
that if you have a like a closed walk in
a graph it's kind of like a tree of
cycles what I mean to say is like if you
do a closed walk in a graph you walk
around for a while and then maybe you
come back to a vertex you've been before
and that gives you like a simple cycle
and you can kind of like pop it off and
then like keep following the walk and
then you maybe hit like another vertex
you've been before and you've completed
another cycle you can kind of pop it off
and so like a closed walk is somehow
composed from collections of cycles and
because of that and like some neo
generating function stuff you can go
from here to here
and therefore you can try to do the same
thing for that was about the
characteristic polynomial and we know a
story for the coefficients of the
matching polynomial and the additive
characteristic polynomial as well and
therefore we can try to do this
generating function stuff to get at the
eigenvalues or the power sums of the
eigenvalues of or the just the power
sums of the roots of the matching
polynomial and the additive
characteristic polynomial so let me
repeat this story but for the matching
polynomial so again for the matching
polynomial it's kind of sum generating
function for matchings disjoint
collections of edges and guardzilla 81
showed that the K power some of the
roots of the matching polynomial exactly
counts the number of closed length K
tree like walks in G where tree like
walk in a graph is like one where you're
walking you're only allowed to come back
to a vertex by like immediate
backtracking so it kind of looks like
like depth-first search trees kind of
things and why do the roots of the
matching polynomial count tree like
walks well if you go to this it's
somehow because a tree like walk in the
same way as before or it's kind of like
what you get if you take edges and
connect them in a tree-like fashion so
you can also prove this fact by
generating functions stuff
okay and so now you can do the same
story for the additive characteristic
polynomial in the same way that the
coefficients of this additive
characteristic polynomial were kind of
generating functions for collections of
disjoint cycles where each cycle appears
wholly within some atom if you do this
story you find that the power sum of the
roots of the additive characteristic
polynomial equals the number of closed
length K free like walks we invented
this goofy term in the atom set and I
won't exactly say what is a free like
walk but it's basically a walk in the
normal graph which is the sum of the
atoms which has the property that like
when you're doing this thing of walking
around and you repeat a vertex and pop
off a cycle but cycle should come wholly
from one of the atoms so it's again kind
of like these close walks that you get
by attaching cycles from the atoms
together in a tree-like fashion
so this kind of finally made us happy
because okay now we can attack the roots
of this additive characteristic
polynomial we can get some story on them
in a combinatorial fashion as like the
number of free like walks that are of a
given length decay and indeed once more
like the the tree like walks in a graph
G or exactly you know the free like
walks that exist when you do this
operation of taking a graph and
splitting it up as the sum of edge
graphs because then the only like cycles
that exist and the atoms are single
edges okay so the sort of the randomness
is that you get this condition that one
cycle has to only one phone yes that's
right it kills all the cycles that don't
have just one color believe it or not
I'm almost done yes no proof on that
track let's you know
no I don't know any linear algebraic
proof of this fact
okay so as I believe I know we're almost
done because uh what you can do now if
you care about the largest eigenvalue in
the graph is like fix the number of
vertices to be like a constant and take
K to be like SuperDuper large and then
the K power some of these roots will
just be dominated by like the largest
magnitude of roots the power of K okay
here just in case it's like a negative
the root is negative but anyway the
maximum magnitude of roots of this
additive characteristic polynomial which
is the thing we're trying to show is
bounded by the spectral radius of the
infinite graph is that number L such
that the number of clothes length 2k
free like walks in the atoms is
proportional to L to the 2k now this
kind of gives like a in some sense a
combinatorial interpretation of the
maximum magnitude root in this additive
characteristic polynomial and you can
always compare this for example to like
you know the maximum root of the
matching polynomial of a graph is that
number L such that the number of closed
length to K 3 like walks in the graph is
proportional to L to the 2k
okay Rahul's to show that this is at
most spectral radius of this infinite
graph so how are you gonna get the
spectral radius of this infinite adder
of product graph into the picture
well again by the trace method if you
will so the spectral radius of this
infinite graph is also that number are
such that the number of closed length 2k
walks many sort just normal close 2k
walks of any sort in the safe in a graph
from the worst starting vertex or in
fact any starting vertex is proportional
to R to the 2k so to show that this is
that most this that L is that most are
it's the places to show that distinct
closed free like walks in the graphs
correspond to distinct closed walks in
this additive product graph or if you
want to imagine back to if you know the
stuff a little bit the matching
polynomial this would be like showing if
you have a graph the number of tree like
walks of a given length in the graph is
at most the number of closed walks in
the universal cover tree of that same
length and so basically you just need
that like distinct tree like or free
like walks in these these atoms
correspond to distinct closed walks in
the out of product graphs and this is my
joke this is obvious from the
definitions except I didn't tell you the
definitions of any objects here but
suffice it to say like the whole
definition of this additive product
graph is such that like you know walks
in it kind of look like walks in the the
some of some of the base graphs but
where you're only allowed to come back
to a vertex by like completing a cycle
that's in one of the atoms so once you
process the definitions it's a done and
so you can get this kind of comparison
theorem between the roots or the eigen
value is without actually knowing what
these numbers are
so this is a picture that may slightly
help you remind you what's going on and
this is where I'll stop thank you are
there some good candidates for uses of
expanders with extra structure yeah I'm
glad yes Peter do you want to answer
that question
uh-huh so the question was like are
there good uses for you know you know
it's kind of like restricting like
optimal spectral expanders but like
among graphs that look in a certain way
like oh maybe they're for regular but
they also every vertex participates in
some cycles or something forth so our
original motivation was from a study of
constraint satisfaction problems random
constraint satisfaction problems have
you know a little bit this if you have
not you're like taking a random regular
instance of three sets so we have like a
random like and variables and like a
random 3sat instance on it so each
constrain involves three variables and
let's say it's regular so each vertex
participates in the same number of
constraints D you know three seconds
straight or even better like a not all
equal 3sat constraint it's kind of like
a triangle on the three vertices and so
kind of like the graph underlying this
random 3sat instance it looks like a
random graph it's like the additive
product of D triangles like I mean it's
like a bunch of triangles strung
together and a random fashion every
point participating in D and a lot of
algorithms associated with random
concerete satisfactions are interested
in like the rock and Valley is
semi-definite programming your likes to
this you know your we were motivated in
previous papers to understand the
eigenvalues of random large regular
graphs that like are composed from they
don't look like trees that are composed
from like small things like triangles
and that's partly how we got on this
subject and then I think Peter also
finished a paper where it's also made a
way to look for some quantum reasons for
like finite size graphs that locally
resemble some infinite graphs like for
example this will cycle back around to
this for example this
this graph so funny graphs would
resemble this graph locally there are
quotients of it where you can say that
the eigenvalues of this finite graph are
similar to the eigenvalue I mean one
deficiency that this has it's like it's
only it's a familiar one it's only
controlling the second-largest
eigenvalue be really great to show you
know that you know random additive lips
have spectrum that's like contained in
the spectrum where that resembles the
whole spectrum of the infinite graph in
terms of both sides are bounded and you
know like the infinite by regular tree
has a spectrum that looks like the
disjoint union of two intervals it'd be
cool if you know the finite graphs that
are lifts of it also had spectra that
looked like that that's beyond the reach
of what we can currently show
yeah like the specter of these internet
graphs can you say anything nice about
those other we have lots of components
would be good question the specter of
these infinite graphs so this study
before in the case of free products of
vertex-transitive graphs which is the
case that we are additive products also
include and okay it's got the extremely
simple cases like this is simple enough
although it took like the PhD thesis of
mcLaughlin to work it out you can
literally exactly say what the spectrum
is and in gender-role you can kind of
sum like implicit description of the
spectrum involving like solutions of
systems of equations and you can kind of
make it explicit in the case that's not
explicit you can get you can kind of
make it explicit in the case where it's
like free products of cycles so things
that look like this but for the most
part you can't really explicitly say
what the spectrum look like except in
some pretty simple cases
yeah here it's in the way length the
hardest part of cognizant single group
is pushed away part time yeah yeah yeah
well you could argue that's great I mean
hey no I don't even have to know what it
is like if we can still do yeah I know I
understand yeah yeah I'm just joking
around
yeah I mean it is funny that we bound it
without knowing what it is I mean you
can know it is by other techniques any
other takes that look like this in some
cases there's really great like kind of
survey paper this by this person called
when now you know which I can recommend
where he like really explains how it the
best way to get out the spectrum of free
products of finite graphs well yeah
after a while except in simple cases
like you don't have it a very explicit
description for them yeah it's the
squirrel stuff I mean I haven't anything
new or at least seen artists working on
it yeah I would like to get a good
description of it actually yeah so it's
upset the vocal SQ methods are the same
methods that one can use to come
implicitly compute this spectrum but the
final result is not like a number it's
like Oh involves like okay the roots of
like a system of polynomial equations
yes yes yes I mean it's yeah it's some
sense it is explicit it's not like super
explicit but it's pretty good
okay thanks a lot
[Applause]